i wonder
if the sun
debates dawn some mornings not wanting
to rise out of bed from under the down
feather horizon
if the sky grows tired of being
everywhere at once adapting to the mood
swings of the weather
if clouds drift off trying to hold
themselves together make deals with
gravity to loiter a little longer
i'll wonder if rain is scared
of falling if she has trouble letting go
if snowflakes get sick of being perfect
all the time each one trying to be one
of a kind i wonder if stars wish upon
themselves before they die
if they need to teach their young how to
shine
i wonder if shadows long to just for
once feel the sun
if they get lost in the shuffle not
knowing where they're from i wonder if
sunrise and sunset respect each other
even though they've never met if storms
have regrets if volcanoes get stressed
if compost believes in life
after death
i wonder
if breath
ever thinks of suicide
if the wind just wants to sit still
sometimes and watch the world pass him
by
if smoke was born knowing how to rise if
rainbows get shy backstage not sure if
their colors match right
i wonder if lightning needs an alarm
clock to know when to crack if rivers
ever stop and think of turning back if
streams meet the wrong sea and their
whole lives run off track
i wonder if the snow
wants to be black
if the soil thinks she's too dark if
butterflies want to cover up their marks
if rocks are self-conscious of their
weight if mountains are insecure
of their strength
i wonder if waves get discouraged
crawling up the sand only to be pulled
back again to where they began if land
feels stepped upon
if sand feels insignificant if trees
need to question their lovers to know
where they stand
if branches wave at the crossroads
unsure of which way
to grow
if leaves understand they're
replaceable
and they still dance
when the wind blows
i wonder
where the moon goes when she is in
hiding i want to find her there and
watch the ocean spin
from a distance
listen to her stir
in her sleep
effort
give way
to existence
[Music]
you